[Musik]
könnte ich biete einen kaffee haben wie
geht es ihnen
danke gut aber vielleicht bald nicht
mehr wenn weiterhin jeder seine abgase
in die luft bläst und nicht sie
schon wieder haben muss wenn er
minutenlang seinen motor nicht abstellt
dann ist das nicht nur lärmbelästigung
es ist auch schlecht für die umwelt
vielleicht wollte er den wagen auf
weizen wenn die belastung weiter zunimmt
und die klimaprognosen der forscher und
experten eintreten dann wird sich
hierbei so so alles erwerben
herzlichen glückwunsch also ich werde
nicht böse über eine klimaänderung die
kälte heute wirklich furchtbar die
globale erwärmung ist eine tatsache es
wird immer wärmer und es werden immer
mehr treibhausgase in die atmosphäre
geblasen von menschen die herz kommen
sie schon seit der ihnen eigentlich
damit sie ihm das alles durchgehen
lassen
mehr als sie
[Musik]